Speaker 1: Let's go to William from Las
Vegas. William, you're on the air. Hello,
David, can you hear me, I can hear you fine,
I just got back from Vegas a few days ago.
Speaker 5: I know I was actually down to the
Strip. I was kind of keeping an eye to see if I
spotted you, but chances are I was pretty far from
you. So, sir, I was wondering if you could help me
craft a water cooler argument, which I'm sure a
lot of other people are having. OK? And it may
sound off the rails, but we'll end it together.
So from my understanding, in the early 2000s,
school districts started to teach common core
math, and it took a while for for teachers to
get training on how to teach common core math
with a lot of resources, curriculum testing,
and then it's still working out. So we're
actually using that as the standard.
So knowing that we're understanding
that with the argument
that critical race theory is being taught
right now, wouldn't it make sense that it took
time to teach teachers a graduate level? From what
I understand, a social or humanities elective?
And I'm sorry, I lost my train of thought.
Well, it makes sense that it took time
to instruct teachers how to teach this
very complicated theory. From K to 12,
even though it's not necessarily in the
curriculum and every time I have this argument,
my question is, well, which curriculum is teaching
this? Which public school because they all publish
their curriculum? I've now got an answer on that.
But but that's kind of where where I'm formulating
my argument as we go towards the midterms.
Speaker 1: But so what? What is the argument
you're trying to make? You're trying to make
the argument that critical race theory just
isn't being taught. I mean, it's basically
not being taught. That's that's true as far
as K through 12 is concerned. But what is
the argument you're trying to formulate?
Speaker 5: So you're right. So it's basically
in association with when people say in they're
teaching critical race theory, they say,
Well, well, how is this happening with
the trained teachers for years? How to teach
common core math? And we've not heard anything
about teachers being taught critical race
theory. So basically is a debate. Interesting.
Speaker 1: OK? Let me see if
I understand. So you're saying
we knew for so long that this thing called Common
Core Math was coming in and we know teachers were
being trained on how to teach it because the
teachers can't teach it unless they're trained.
If critical race theory is really everywhere.
How is it everywhere, given that the teachers
haven't even been trained? How to teach it?
Speaker 5: We landed safely. That's exactly
the point I was trying to make. Yes.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's that's interesting.
I think the problem is here is how
the right will respond. They'll say,
No, no, no. Here's the thing college that
the colleges that the teachers went to their
entire framework is critical race theory. So the
teachers already have the knowledge that they'll
say something like that. So I don't know that you
would convince too many people, unfortunately.
Speaker 5: And my maneuver to
that is what teachers don't
teach anything that's not on the curriculum.
Speaker 1: They'll say, but they are that
they'll just say no, but they are teaching it,
Speaker 5: they're teaching it. Oh, so it's so
it's the no true Scotsman that they'll come
back with. Yeah, probably. OK. Yeah. All right.
Speaker 1: It's an uphill battle, my friend,
but I'm glad you're thinking about it.
Speaker 5: Well, I'm definitely thinking local
and hopefully you you enjoy Las Vegas while you're
here. I did. Good. All right. Thank you, sir.
Speaker 1: OK, very good. Take care.
There is beautiful phone call from
Las Vegas. Hard to hard to beat that.